Це український супутник дистанційного зондування землі  "Січ-2-1".
Його можна сміливо називати "космічним довгобудом". Адже роботу над ним почали ще в 2013-му, щоб  запустити в космос у 2017-му.
Утім, лише зараз у супутника вже під новим ім'ям "Січ-2-30" з’явився шанс таки потрапити на орбіту -
ймовірно, в грудні 2021 року за допомогою ракети Falcon 9 компанії Ілона Маска SpaceX.
Він повністю зібраний, зараз проводяться електричні випробування систем на їхнє функціонування.
Я можу сказати, більше половину випробування виконали.
Найближчим часом закінчимо ці випробування і  будемо готові до відправки цього апарату на космодром наприкінці цього року.
Востаннє Україна запускала свій супутник "Січ-2" на своїй ракеті-носії "Дніпро" з російського космодрому в 2011 році.
Запуск сучасного космічного апарату "Січ-2" був присвячений 20-річчю Незалежності України...
Замість запланованих п'яти років через втрату енергопостачання він пробув на орбіті лише 16 місяців.
"Січ-2-30" є його модифікацією і також вироблений у Дніпрі в КБ "Південне".
Супутник має бути запущений на честь 30-річчя Незалежності України.
Принаймні таке завдання поставив перед урядом президент Зеленський.
До запуску в грудні - 9 місяців. За даними Державного космічного агентства України, актуальний стан готовності супутника становить 75%.
Готовність наземних станцій, які будуть керувати ним та приймати, обробляти  інформацію - 35%.
Науковці, конструктори та чиновники запевняють DW, що підстав сумніватися в тому, що старт таки відбудеться, немає.
Хоча немає поки і затвердженої урядом постанови про виділення грошей на підготовку.
Згідно з підрахунками Державного космічного агентства, необхідно не менше 140 млн гривень.
Одні лишень послуги SpaceX, за різними оцінками, обійдуться в не менше 1 мільйона доларів.
Перемовини з компанією Ілона Маска тривають з кінця минулого року.
Наразі обговорюються технічні моменти і до підписання остаточного договору про запуск супутника сторони ще не дійшли.
Він був розроблений для запуску на іншій ракеті. Його розташування було на диспенсері вертикально.
Під час перемовин зі SpaceX ми зрозуміли, що він має бути розташований інакше.
Є графік запуску супутника на ракеті SpaceX. Попередні перемовини з компанією дають нам розуміння,
що на ракеті, яка буде запущена в грудні 21-го року,  є можливість розташувати цей супутник.
Керувати супутником і обробляти інформацію з нього має Національний центр управління та випробування космічних засобів,
який підпорядкований Державному космічному агентству.
Тут працюють не лише цивільні науковці, а й військові.
Наразі Україна має можливість отримувати дані з 21-го супутника інших країн, зокрема ЄС. Не уся інформація є безкоштовною.
Деякі дані доводиться купувати.
Запуск свого супутника дозволить заощаджувати чималі кошти, запевняють в Державному космічному агентстві.
Це мільйони доларів.  І ми маємо розуміти ще один момент. Коли це наш супутник і ми не закуповуємо ніяких фото,
то ми можемо отримувати стільки знімків, скільки нам потрібно, без обмежень.
У потрібний час і потрібній частині країни.
В першу чергу цього чекають військові.  Їм потрібна своя і більш точна інформація про те, що відбувається в Криму,
в Чорному й Азовському морях, на кордонах з Росією, Білоруссю і на окупованих територіях.
Серед іншого військові аналізують і екологічні проблеми цих територій.
На території Донбасу затоплюються шахти. Починають просідати цілі житлові райони. І ви бачите район міста Суходольск.
Рівень просадок - 29 см на рік. Через кілька років тут жити буде неможливо, бо будинки будуть тріскатися.
Проте супутник "Січ-2-30"  не зможе забезпечити Україні повну інформаційну незалежність.
Знімки з інших апаратів доведеться купувати й надалі. "Січ-2-30" має роздільну здатність знімків 8 метрів.
Якщо його дані порівняти з ось цими знімками з іноземних супутників з роздільною здатністю 50 -70 сантиметрів,
то стає зрозуміло, що "Січ-2-30" передаватиме менш детальну інформацію.
На 8-метровому оці всі літаки будуть як одна точка.
Ті, хто вміють працювати з супутниковими даними, зможуть зрозуміти, що відбувається на тому аеродромі.
Представники космічної галузі хочуть усе зробити, аби запуск супутника був успішним.
Адже, на їхнє переконання, Україна після 10-річної відсутності у космосі має повернути собі статус космічної держави.
Проте чи не застарів довгобуд "Січ-2-30" на тлі швидкого розвитку космічних технологій?
Ці технології були в свій час передовими, але не можна сказати, що вони застаріли.
Тому що в супутникових технологіях є дві складові: платформа і корисне навантаження.
Платформа - база, на якій виводиться цей супутник на орбіту. Ця платформа не має терміну придатності. На неї можна розміщувати будь що.
Треба зрозуміти, що не можна отак відразу на перший запуск за останні 10 років покладати великі надії та сподівання.
Але він має відбутися, щоб технології вдосконалювалися, ми отримували практичний досвід.
"Січ-2-30" можна назвати оглядовим супутником. На його дані дуже чекають, зокрема, у міністерствах та відомствах,
які на тлі земельної реформи мають звірити дані земельного кадастру з супутниковими знімками.
Уряд буде мати можливість перевірити і те, чи дотримуються великі заводи екологічних норм,
як працює аграрний сектор: наприклад, скільки полів дійсно засіяно, і відповідно робити економічні прогнози і прогнози щодо зміни клімату.
Бачимо останній циклон, який трішки додав снігової маси. А наприклад, південні регіони страждають від посухи.
Зміна клімату йде, відбувається  опустелювання південних регіонів: Одещина, Миколаївщина.
Навіть зараз в деяких місяцях мінімально снігового покриву.
Правоохоронці та рятувальники також хочуть мати оперативний доступ до супутникових знімків,
щоб мати можливість зупиняти контрабандистів на суші і на морі, знати, де саме почалися лісові пожежі,
аби вчасно їх гасити, щоб володіти повною інформацію щодо масштабів повеней.
На локалізацію паводка в Закарпатті було виділено 8 млрд гривень.
За цією технологією можна було зрозуміти, кому конкретно це було потрібно.
Ця сума  була б меншою і більш ефективнішо використана.
Міндовкілля вже розпочало співпрацю з Державним космічним агентством.
Тут кажуть, що запуск супутника дасть можливість постійно моніторити вирубки лісу,
вчасно реагувати на незаконні рубки, відстежувати стан водойм та забруднення повітря.
Наступним кроком, я так сподіваюсь, буде моніторинг надр.
Тобто ми будемо бачити, де копанка знаходиться, де нелегальний  кар’єр. В тому числі уявіть економічний ефект від цього.
Те ж саме сміттєзвалище, те ж саме забудова прибрежно-захисних смуг. Це насправді дуже серйозний інструмент.
Ринок космічних послуг стрімко розвивається.
Україна, на думку голови Асоціації "Космос", має всі шанси стати серйозним гравцем на ньому:
брати участь у різних міжнародних програмах, зокрема з освоєння Місяця,
повноцінно інтегруватися в Європейську космічну систему, що передбачає Угода про асоціацію України з ЄС.
Це дозволить іншим галузям економіки отримати замовлення і створити нові робочі місця.
Також це відкриває двері для іноземних інвестицій в український космос.
У нас є наземні станції спостереження, наземні станції прийому і обробки інформації супутникової.
І ця інформація може бути як з нашого супутника, так і з інших.
Якщо ми покажемо ефективність роботи наших станцій наземних,
то вони можуть бути включені в європейську інфраструктуру і співпрацювати з наземними станціями ЄС.
У нас вже понад 2 роки працює спільний з Європою проект "Копернікус".
Національний центр є оператором датахабу, який розташований під Києвом, який приймає інформацію з супутників
системи "Копернікус" і обробляє.
Утім, реально це лише за умови державної підтримки, яка може буде надана у разі ухвалення державної космічної програми, якої немає вже кілька років.
Команда президента Зеленського затвердила лише її концепцію.
Вона передбачає, що супутник "Січ-2-30" з терміном експлуатації 5 років буде доповнений кількома супутниками.
Їх слід запускати майже щороку.
Ми маємо напрацювання по більш досконалим зразкам. Вони знаходяться на різних стадіях.
Деякі - на стадії проєктування, інші - вже виготовлення конструкторської документації
та виготовлена матеріальна частина платформ інших супутників.
На виробництво супутника "Січ-2-30" КБ "Південне" і держава з 2014-го року витратили 170 мільйонів гривень.
Більшу частину -110 млн. грв профінансувало бюро.
Проєкт міг би коштувати менше, якби державне фінансування було більшим, а рішення про його вчасний запуск ухвалили в 2017-му році.
Відповідно до технічних характеристик нині у супутника фактично є лише один шанс запуститися  - за допомогою компанії Ілона Маска.
Інакше його можна знову розбирати.
У Дніпрі сподіваються, що до цього не дійде і очікують на ухвалення найближчим часом Державної космічної програми,
яка гарантує галузі майже 3 млрд гривень щорічного фінансування упродовж п'яти років.